wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
deine firma stellt doch internetseiten
für design digitale lösung
marketingkonzepte blogs die ok ich
möchte wissen ob du mir hilft ich
brauche mehr kunden funktioniert das mit
einer neuen website eine webseite allein
reichte nicht
du musst in den sozialen netzwerken
aktiv sein
die leute müssen deine seiten licon sie
müssen die möglichkeit haben zu posten
mit dem smartphone tablet laptop immer
und überall
ich habe nur in kleinen fahrradladen ich
denke eine bearbeitete website reicht
erstmal ich meine ich benutze nie
sozialer netzwerke dann solltest du
vielleicht mal damit anfangen
aber du kannst dich doch super damit aus
kannst mir nicht einfach eine website
erstellen
ich habe dich gefragt ob du eine
webseite für mich machen kannst
ich habe mitarbeiter für so was ja
können die das dann machen wir kriegen
aufträge von riesigen farmen und ein
laden hier ist einfach zu klein
es lohnt sich nicht aber es ist mein
fahrrad leihen und ich bin deine tante
vielleicht hat nico recht interessierst
dich überhaupt nicht für deine familie
tut mir leid